GTA 5 was released three years ago and
still has a huge following and
playerbase due to GTA online but why do
we keep coming back to GTA well it's the
regular DLC which of course is free this
week is the Halloween edition which has
a few delights for you to sample so here
are five things you need to do in GTA
online over Halloween we'll start with
the most impressive item which is the CC
Sanctus motorcycle which is a true
Halloween treat featuring a sculpt with
bright red eyes to act as headlights
the chassis resembles a ribcage and the
back also gives you an increased defense
and attack damage bonus in addition to
health regeneration when riding this
will be very useful for the biker DLC
you've just been playing to grab this
bike get on your browser on your mobile
phone and go to southern san andreas'
autos calm and as long as you have 1.9
million dollars you can order this bad
boy in many colors including very
masculine pink head back to your garage
and your new wheels should be waiting
for you if it isn't don't worry just
wait for a text from San Andres autos
and check again there are also a few new
t-shirts to try out when you log into
GTA online the Twilight knife and
butchery shirts look like slasher movie
apparel in addition if you add the
motorcycle you'll unlock a third t-shirt
which will be delivered to you on
November the 7th a new game mode has
been added for the Halloween
celebrations too pitting angels against
Devils in a bloody shootout playing as
an angel you will receive improved
health and weaponry during daylight but
during the night this pushes over to The
Devil's and you only have a hatchet to
hack down your opponents the day/night
cycle clips every 60 seconds allowing
for some hair-raising moments this
update also brings back some favorites
from last Halloween so if you missed the
lurcher hearse or the Franken strange
you can get those now I spent my first
day of the update cosplaying as Ghost
Rider and showing off my silky driving
skills I am a ton from PlayStation
granade I'll see you online